in the recent film starring Tom Holland
Peter Parker cooks up his own webbing in
his high school chemistry class now he
could have made it out of anything like
fishing line or even steel and yet he
chooses to replicate spider silk spider
silk
this kid is trusting his life to a
flimsy looking strand of our arachnid
goop but it turns out if Peters web is
anything like real spider silk then his
web slinging antics are more realistic
than they might appear now spider silk
doesn't look very durable
after all a strand can be as little as
140th the thickness of a human hair but
pound for pound it's stronger than steel
so if you twist it spider silk into a
thread that was two millimeters wide as
thick as a strand of spaghetti it could
support 900 pounds before breaking
strong enough for a polar bear to hang
from so a scrawny kid like spider-man
he's got this and that's just for a two
millimeter diameter wedding if he needs
more he just makes a little bit thicker
and it could support even more way
that's physicist Jim cacao Leo's the
author of the physics of superheroes he
says that the secret to spider silk
strength is its structure real spider
silk has two major components extremely
rigid nano crystals that make the silk
sturdy and stretchy elastic polymers
that make it pliable that combination of
tough and flexible makes the silk
extremely hard to tear and if you look
at Peters lab notes it looks like he
tries to mimic that same structure so it
looks like it is a set of organic
molecules that he is using and he's
trying to combine them in ways to
polymerize them to basically take these
complex molecules and link them together
in longer chains that would then
presumably fall down
and develop these nano crystals and the
elastic polymers but Peter may have gone
one step further and actually made one
improvement to a synthetic silk I think
that instead of these little nano
crystals that of proteins that spiders
use he might be using carbon nanotubes
to provide the strength of legitimation
carbon nanotubes are basically a sheet
of carbon atoms that's been rolled up
into a tube and if Jim's right peter is
one smart high school student because
these tiny tubes are actually some of
the strongest material known to humans
in fact there are over a hundred times
as strong as steel and that's when
they're microscopic so a spaghetti thin
strand of this stuff like what we see in
spider-man it could support far more
than just 900 pounds I would be able to
support over 40,000 pounds suddenly that
very scene doesn't seem so far-fetched
especially since we have the technology
to make those nanotubes in real life
scientists at the University of
Cincinnati for example I figured out how
to grow carbon nanotubes in a lab and
then spool them into threads sadly those
threads aren't meant for skyscraper
swinging antics
the researchers goal is a tad more
practical if you could manufacture it
and make threads out of carbon nanotubes
you could make lightweight clothing that
would be stronger than Kevlar so when
you really think about it the most
unrealistic thing about Peter Parker's
homemade webbing is that a high schooler
figured out how to make it in his chem
class
you
[Music]